So, OK, let this is now.
I want to be clear that this is not my idea.
Doctors are saying that based on Donald Trump's
behavior of the last 72 to 96 hours, he needs
a psychiatric evaluation.
All right.
And so we saw where I mean, you could go back
years, but for this episode we saw on Sunday,
Donald Trump, while contagious with coronavirus,
Donald Trump went on a Korona ride around
Walter Reed Hospital with Secret Service agents
in a hermetically sealed Secret Service vehicle
to wave to his supporters.
This started to raise some red flags that,
you know, if you've not been paying attention
the last four years, maybe Trump is not well,
mentally, maybe Trump is not well cognitively.
Then Donald Trump pulled a bizarre stunt where
he checked himself out of Walter Reed Medical
Center on Monday, flew back to the White House,
walked up the back steps or the front steps,
I don't know which is the back or the front
of the White House.
And defiantly removed his mask in his orange
glory and filmed a completely propagandistic
video, the likes of which we anticipate seeing
out of North Korea, but not necessarily the
United States.
Even Donald Trump Junior has now said, according
to Gabriel Sherman in Vanity Fair Monday,
that he thinks Trump is manic.
And that an intervention is needed, well,
liano when who is a CNN medical analyst, a
doctor, a visiting professor at George Washington
University said based on Donald Trump's behavior,
a psychiatric evaluation would be in order
if Trump were her patient and left the hospital
while still infected to go for a car ride.
She would demand a psychiatric evaluation,
tweeting, quote, If Trump were my patient
in unstable condition with contagious illness.
And he suddenly left the hospital to go for
a car ride that endangers himself and others,
I'd call security to restrain him, then perform
a psychiatric evaluation to examine his decision
making capacity.
That's a doctor.
My friends.
This is not normal behavior.
The barrage of manic tweets Monday morning,
Tuesday night, it all basically seals the
deal that Donald Trump may be as desperately
as he needs.
Corona virus isolation needs a psychiatric
evaluation now.
Of course, we have to ask, could this be related
to the dexamethasone, the steroid on which
Donald Trump has been put to treat Corona
virus?
Maybe, yeah.
I mean, why would Trump risk people's lives
just to wave to fans outside of the hospital?
Well, maybe it is the dexamethasone, but maybe
it's just Trump because he doesn't care.
Donald Trump has weaponized narcissism and
has destroyed any semblance of empathy over
the last four years.
Trump even tried tweeting that had he not
done his Korona ride around the hospital.
The media would have said he's wrong not to
do it.
See if you can follow this.
Trump quoted tweet, tweeted, quote, It is
reported that the media is upset because I
got into a secure vehicle to say thank you
to the many fans and supporters who were standing
outside of the hospital for many hours and
even days to pay their respect to their president.
If I didn't do it, media would say rude.
Ridiculous.
There is no one in the media who would have
said if Trump safely stayed in the hospital.
Trump's really bad because he's not driving
around right now with Corona virus.
It's ridiculous.
Secret Service agents were disturbed by it.
A veteran Secret Service agent expressed dismay
at the Korona ride around Walter Reed and
did say that when you were around Trump, it's
difficult for people to say no.
That if you say no, you you you suffer that
that it leads to even worse outcomes.
It is actually scary where we are as a country
right now, because not only do we have a president
who's been incompetent all along, his decision
making capability to the extent that it ever
existed is particularly gone.
And, you know, we can speculate.
Is it the steroids?
Is it the disastrous polling?
Is it that the White House is so highly infected
with virus?
It could be all of these things.
It could be a combination.
OK, it doesn't really matter.
How do you think he ended up in the hospital
with Corona virus?
He tried to make a mockery of facts and science.
And this is where we are right now.
Whether he's fit to serve as president should
not even be a debate at this point in time.
And yet 60 million or more people are still
going to vote for him.
And he could could, could, but hopefully won't.
He could get another four years.
It is an existential threat not only to the
United States, but to humanity for this man
to get another four years.
He is out of control.
It is completely weaponized.
You all know what to do.
I won't even say it.
Let's just go to the break.
You will.
It's four letters, I'll tell you that.
I'll tell you.
And we're 27 days.
OK.
But I'm not gonna actually say it.
You know what
to do.